(audience cheering)
- Hello!
- Hello.
- You just turned 40,
I did too.
- Yeah girl!
- Yes.
- Do you
- 40!
- I wanna show the cake and the banner,
cuz there's something
interesting about it.
It says "Mommy, Mom".
So yeah.
So were they just making
sure you were their mom
or like what?
- Like they're just double checking.
No, my littlest is mommy,
and my my older is he calls me mom,
cuz he's big now, and it just happened.
- [Kelly] He's too cool.
- He's too.
Yeah. He's like I'm too big for mommy.
He also told me the
other day that he's too
big to hold my hands.
(audience groaning)
- Wait, how old?
- That's how quickly
it happens, he's seven.
- So mine is seven.
So my seven year old
girl, like all of a sudden
we were like walking,
like getting ice cream.
I was doing some really
cool cause I'm a cool mom.
And she was just like uh,
and then she saw like an
older girl, like standing,
and all of a sudden she
and I was like, Aah.
I was like, she was embarrassed
of me to hold my hand.
- I was holding my son's
hand in our driveway.
There was nobody
- There's no peer pressure.
- Like get off me,
I'm too old for this now.
My little sad heart just cracked.
- I almost cried.
I was like what?
I was like, I'm cool.
- [Jessica] It's too soon.
- I know, you're like not
supposed to be like this
till like puberty
- At least another,
- I don't know.
- 10 years for boys maybe.
- [Kelly] 10 for me, that's too much.
- Have you noticed things changing at 40?
I have.
Yeah. Yeah.
- A lot of things are changing.
- [Kelly] Yeah, like random hairs.
Like I'm like what?
- [Jessica] Oh, those hairs.
Oh yeah.
- I was like, do I need a razor?
Like what?
- I know you're like, do
I go to the barber now?
- Like what is happening in my face?
Yeah.
- That, and also I'm in
the mirror and going, Ooh
look at those blonde natural.
Oh my God,
- [Kelly] They're not,
- That's not blonde, that's gray.
- What is that?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then do you pull it, do you not?
There's a controversy about pulling
or not pulling a gray hair.
- I know.
I don't really pull it cuz I feel
- [Jessica] I don't either
- I leave it, I get my hair only done.
I'm like literally asked them like
what can I do to only have
to do this twice a year?
- [Jessica] Me too,
- because I don't wanna sit.
I don't wanna do it all the time.
- Me too.
- And so I just leave
them until I get it done,
like whatever, because it's kind
of like Bonnie Rae, it's like cool.
Or like Emmy Lou Harris.
It's like, I feel like
I got a little cooler
- Like fully and I really I'm
hoping that I can be brave
and courageous enough that
as I get even older, I can be
that lady with the white hair.
- See I,
- [Jessica] I hope I can be that brave.
- I'm not sure we have naturally
the same color of hair,
maybe like a dirty blonde.
And I feel like,
- Is it gonna be?
- that's not in our cards.
- It's not?
- I feel like isn't that?
- [Jessica] Are you, you
crushing my dreams right now.
- I am so crushing it.
I feel like it's more
like really dark haired
women that go really,
really bright like that don't you?
- Yeah, but can't you
- [Kelly] We could dye it
- Can't you help it with some
- [Kelly] I will help it.
- Some white highlights.
- I will help it.
I will also help it.
I will help it on my way to Helen Mirren.
- Thank you.
I just, that transitional moment
might be a little rough.
- Yeah. It's okay.
Maybe we'll have another pandemic.
Nobody will see us.
- Perfect.
- And we can blame it on that.
- There you go.
- I love how many things
were blamed on the pandemic.
When we all naturally
did them in the frame,
we're like yeah. Oh,
I'm just wearing this.
Cuz I'm just like so tired.
Cuz the pandemic I'm like I
wore that cuz it was Tuesday.
So that's why your new series though
which you also produce.
That's also awesome.
It's on Hulu.
It's called "Candy" and
it's based on a true story.
- It is.
It's a, it's based, well,
it's a true crime story
based on a real community
in 1980 Wiley, Texas
- It's always Texas.
- It is.
A crime story is, always
what's wrong with us?
- [Jessica] It is always Texas.
I don't know either, but
it's a fascinating story.
This woman, Candy Montgomery,
upstanding citizen,
suburban housewife God
fearing mother of two,
with no history of violence,
and nothing strange in her past, really
In a big way,
enacts, in crazy act of violence,
towards a friend of hers
and changes her life
and this friend's life, and
the whole community basically.
- And then like what made her do that?
Is that just like how?
- That's what I'm always so interested in,
is the psychological element of,
how does that
- You like this stuff,
like "The Sinner", I like, yeah
- I do.
I'm just, I'm interested
in that human thing
of we are all capable of anything.
- Absolutely.
- You know, you feel like,
well, no I would never do that,
but could I be pushed far enough?
Is there something, or would I want
would I wanna protect my kids
to some crazy level that
I would do something
that I could never, I would never expect.
- That's a, an intense role to play.
Do you ever get exhausted from that?
Like playing something so,
- Yes, it's an exhausting
thing to do certainly.
- And you look very different.
- I know.
I love that though.
I love that transformative
- Going into character?
- element.
- That probably helps.
- [Jessica] So much.
- Cause you get in character so much
that it doesn't look like you,
you don't feel like you, so
- You don't feel like
you, you can, you can.
I mean literally be transformed
and transmuted to another time and place.
You know?
- Yeah. Cuz I'm, that's not you,
that's someone else.
- Yeah. That is definitely not me
- Named Candy, but also Sally,
I don't know, I don't know.
- [Jessica] I know, right..
- Those Sally Jesse
Raphael glasses are nice.
- Those are amazing.
Yeah. I see that person.
And I see my, I see my grandmother.
- Oh my God, that's awesome.
- And I feel like everyone
who sees this as like
my grandmother or my
mother looked like that
at some point in their lives
with that great perm and
- Yes, we all had 'em.
What?
- I did too.
- Yep, perm it up.
It always took so long,
and it smelled so bad.
- Smelled so crazy.
- Yeah.
- Smelled so bad that smell.
- What was that smell?
- So your company, it's also
it's Kinder Farms, right?
So what was the big deal?
I know a lot of people, I
feel like when we have kids
we don't care as much about our own bodies
but when we have kids, you're
all of a sudden like, wait
what am I putting on them?
What are I putting in them?
Like, you know, you start worrying.
Is that kind of where
this company came from?
- Definitely, I was in a pharmacy
in the middle of the night,
looking for some kind
of electrolyte solution
that I could give my kid
who was sick at home.
And I was looking for, you
know, anything that I felt was
you know, safe and didn't
have a bunch of junk.
- Dyes, yeah.
- And dyes and are artificial things.
- It's hard to find.
- And there's really
not that much out there.
It is hard to find.
And that was the impetus, my partner,
Jeremy in the company,
he had the same situation
and that's the jumping off point of
we had a different value system
and we wanted to, you know
be able to bring products to families,
to parents who you know, have
a same value system as we do.
And just provide another option.
- Well, and I think we're
getting smarter as a society.
We now are figuring out like, oh my gosh
all these things we've
been taking, we were kids.
You didn't realize what
all those things were.
You know what I'm saying?
Nobody really took the time
or knew the science behind it.
And now you do.
So you freak out and you're like,
wait, I don't wanna do that to my kid.
And then that, you know,
affects them in the long run
and you've done that.
It wasn't their choice.
- That's right.
- [Kelly] That's the pressure.
- The responsibility of
caring for another life
who is not capable of making
their own decisions yet,
is extremely humongous responsibility.
So yeah, I just wanted
great stuff for my kids,
for their immune system
when they're not well.
And we're gonna continue to hopefully
bring out tons of great
products for kids and families.
- I love that it's kinder, that's nice.
- Yeah. We're trying to think
of it as the kinder
pharmaceutical company.
Even though it's
- Kinder to your body
though, kinder, that's nice.
- Kinder to the world, to
your body, to your immunity,
all of it.
- Yeah. It's so good.
I think that's why things like this
do so well, because people
are really craving it
and there's not that option.
So thank you from a mama.
It's very nice
that you do all the hard
work and we benefit from it.
So happy to do it.